the true history of ancient egypt is
far older than what we were taught in
school and in this video
i'm going to give you three examples
that will make you rethink virtually
everything you thought you knew
about the age of the ancient egyptians
you see
according to our textbooks the great
pyramid of giza egypt
was constructed roughly 4 500 years ago
or in the year 2500 bc
but let's be clear they do not know that
with absolute certainty as there are far
too many unanswered
questions and mysteries about the
ancient egyptians
this is why you'll see words like
suggest
when modern historians discuss the
purported age of the great pyramid
because they ultimately do not have
definitive proof
of when it was constructed much less how
so make no mistake
it truly is a mystery and this is where
things start to get
weird because there is new evidence that
has come to light in modern times
that strongly suggests that the world's
oldest
largest and most mysterious structures
ever made
is actually thousands of years older
than what we were taught
let me first share with you an ancient
artifact that very few people are aware
of
which is commonly referred to as the
nubian egg
which was discovered in a 7 000 year old
tomb in the nubian desert of sudan
and i was completely unaware of this
incredible artifact until i
visited the nubian museum in aswan egypt
while i toured ancient egypt sites late
last year
what you're looking at here is a
decorated ostrich egg which
like i said was discovered in a tomb
that was carbon dated
to 7 000 years ago and what do you see
on this egg well if you ask me that is
the depiction
of three pyramids but let me be clear up
front the
so-called experts have said that they
couldn't possibly be pyramid since this
relic is
2500 years older than the great pyramid
of giza so of course
it couldn't possibly be depicting
pyramids thus
they've claimed this must be just a
depiction of mountains
end of story nothing to see here
but when you take a closer look what
on earth are those lines supposed to be
i mean
never mind that this drawing would be
illustrating some pretty
bizarre shaped mountains like i've never
seen before i mean come on this was
found in the nubian desert of sudan
which mountains exactly are is this
supposed to be portraying
i mean if they're going to adamantly
claim that these are just mountains then
which
mountain specifically are they
suggesting it's supposed to be
i took it upon myself to look up the
various mountain chains that are located
in sudan
and i have to say that i found nothing
of the sort i mean is this supposed to
be
of the 9800 foot dariba caldera which
obviously looks nothing like it
or perhaps the tatil mountains in
eastern sudan
um no or what about the eltaka mountains
i have to say that that's obviously the
best choice when compared to the others
but that would have to be a rather
terrible pictorial example of them on
this egg i mean just compare
the two of them together and i'd say
that it's simply not a match considering
how sharply shaped this depiction is
and i'm just not seeing a connection
here and to be fair nobody that's
claimed
that this pictorial image is of
mountains has actually claimed that they
are of the altaka mountains
like i said i simply took it upon myself
to research various mountains located in
sudan to see if there was any type of
connection
and with that said i have to say that
the nubian pyramids located in sudan
seem to resemble the angle of the
drawings based on the unique steepness
compared to other pyramids such as the
ones we find in giza
however these pyramids were constructed
some 2
000 years after the pyramids of giza and
approximately
5 000 years after the nubian egg itself
but most importantly and getting back to
the point i made a moment ago about the
lines on the depiction
let's be real this is exactly what
pyramids are they consist of layers of
steps
which result in the pyramid itself so i
have to say that this
in itself rules out that they are
mountains i like to think for myself and
this just is not what mountains look
like
which is exactly what the experts claim
them to be
and they do not allege them to be of the
nubian pyramids either
but again of some unspecified mountains
and there just so happens to be three of
them
which is what we happen to find on the
giza plateau
relatively not far away up the nile
river
the same place where modern researchers
have already suggested
that the pyramids of giza are much much
older than what we thought possible
but of course nothing here is certain
and this depiction
certainly does not prove that the great
pyramid is more than 7 000 years old
however it is certainly worthy of
discussion and debate
nevertheless there is more to this egg
than just those pyramid mountains or
whatever you want to call them notice
the zigzag shape to the right of it
could this be the nile river i mean
it's not hard to suggest it when you
consider the fact that the nile does
indeed zigzag for thousands of mountains
all the way down to the nubian desert of
sudan and not only that
it happens to be the on the right or
let's say the eastern side of the
potentially annotated pyramids which is
exactly the case of what we find in
cairo with the nile river being east of
the giza plateau
but that's not all this is just one side
of the egg
when we go to the other side we get
another depiction of the same pyramid
shape formation
however with this different unique
formation
to the right of it could this once again
be depicting the nile river because
when you consider the area of the nile
known as the fiom oasis which is
south and west of cairo and which today
resembles the shape of a heart
consider how this shape on the egg stems
sharp to the left or
that say west and is now below or let's
say south
of the possible pyramid depiction this
is very similar to what we see in egypt
the fiam oasis like i said is south of
giza
and extends to the west now here is one
point that must be mentioned which
is that the path and shape of the nile
river today
is not the same as it was thousands of
years ago the river has moved paths
many times over the last several
thousand years as this has been
something that's been studied
since extensively so we should not
assume that the depictions on this egg
assuming that it is of the nile would be
exactly the same
as it were when it was drawn some 7000
years ago and of course
these are indeed rudimentary drawings
onto an ostrich egg so it's not like it
would be perfect
or much less drawn to scale either but
come on
the two drawings of the so-called
mountains on this egg
have lines that go right through them so
i'm just gonna say it
i think that this is annotating pyramids
i mean i've already been
highly suspicious that the great pyramid
and
the pyramids of giza as well as certain
other sites around egypt
are much much older than what they are
alleged to be
but when it comes to sciencing things
out i'll save my suspicions for another
video
because there is another fascinating
aspect of this egg that really makes me
wonder and my friend johanna james who
was traveling with me in egypt last year
made a great video
discussing it which real quick go check
out her channel you'll love it but
look at the top here of this egg these
circular
rings hmm where on earth have we seen
that before
the lost city of atlantis was said to
consist of three rings of water and two
of land and let's not forget
that the legend of the lost city of
atlantis originates from the ancient
egyptians themselves
that's a fact that most people are not
aware of as the ancient greek
philosopher plato
gets all the credit but egypt is where
the legend of a lost
circular city consisting of three rings
of water and two of land
comes from so when you look at this here
tell me that's not what we're seeing or
at least possibly i mean i really wish i
had better photos but the great news is
that i'll be back in egypt
this october with brian forrester and i
will be sure to get high definition
pictures
and videos of this egg this time around
but
i don't know guys i think there's
something here here and
whoever the person was that was buried
with this egg was perhaps trying to tell
a story of
this person's various travels through
life or possibly even
passed down and spread the tale of
destroyed ancient city of atlantis which
the egyptians were said to have came
from
this is something i will discuss more in
another video but going to back to my
main point which is that
egypt was much older than what we were
taught let me bring you
to the second point of this video which
is another profound discovery
that came about late last year at the
same time that i happen to be traveling
through egypt
what you're seeing here are pieces of
ancient cedar wood
that have been preserved after being
removed from the great pyramid back in
1872
it was then taken to a museum in britain
but unfortunately it went missing for
more than a century not long after
arriving at the museum
and it turns out that was due to a
filing era and it sat in the museum's
archives for well over a hundred years
but in late 2020 it was rediscovered
within the museum's archives and when it
was carbon dated
researchers were blown away at the
findings so
get this at a minimum this wood dates
back
at least 514 years older
than the suggested date for the great
pyramids construction
and that was the headline that made
rounds around the world that a piece of
wood that is 500 years older than the
pyramid
in which it was found inside of however
there was a range of dating for the wood
that most articles did not mention which
is that it could be as much as
781 years older than the suggested
construction date of the great pyramid
that's 267 years more than 514 years so
in other words nearly 800 years older
than the purported age of the great
pyramid
i mean that's closer to a thousand years
older than the pyramids and yes i
shouldn't get carried away with rounding
up
but that's substantial but that aside
what are the possible explanations for a
5
000 year old piece of wood being found
in a 4500 year old pyramid
well the experts came up with three
different possible explanations but i
have to say
that of the three of them two of them
are unbelievably weak excuses for
example
one suggested possibility is that the
wood was already 500 years old when it
was used for the construction of the
pyramid because trees
were rare in the deserts of egypt so it
would have been recycled but
you know i'm sorry that has to be one of
the laziest possibilities out there i
mean i just don't buy it
because to suggest that a piece of wood
would be continuously recycled for five
centuries
sounds less than feasible especially
when you consider that it would be used
to construct
something as enormously heavy and
massive as a freaking
pyramid i mean come on give me a break
but another
possibility was that the 500 year old
wood was intentionally used because of
its age
in order to honor the pharaoh and the
extensive age and history of
egypt now nah i'm not buying that either
i mean really
i mean come on hey look here's some
really old wood let's just throw this
all in here in the pyramid and
honor the pharaoh give it an artistic
edge based on its age i mean come on
please
but let me say this the best and most
probable possibility given was that the
cedar tree itself may have already been
hundreds of years old when it was cut
down
and used for the pyramids construction
and when we consider that cedars can
live up to a thousand years in age
that certainly is a possibility i feel
like more scientific testing needs to be
done on this wood to establish various
possibilities of its age and where it
may have originated from but when we
think of an ostrich
egg being with pyramids drawn on it
being placed inside of a seven thousand
year old tomb
it makes me think that the cedar wood
itself was placed inside the pyramid
far earlier than 4 500 years ago now
the third point of this video to build
the case at the true age of the ancient
egyptians is thousands of years older
than we thought
brings me back to a point that i've
mentioned in many prior videos but it
must be repeated as much as possible
so far more people can become aware of
it as it is unbelievably significant
scientific evidence that is ultimately
undeniable to anyone that's actually
done the research
which is the remarkable amount of rain
water erosion around the enclosure of
the great sphinx of giza to make a long
story short
we all know that egypt is one dry place
and the last time it had any significant
rainfall was nearly 9
000 years ago yet there appears to be
many
thousands of years of water erosion
around the limestone bedrock of its
enclosure that it was carved out of
this becomes even more interesting when
we consider that the sphinx itself was
known to have been consumed with sand
for thousands of years so the question
becomes
when did the rain water erosion happen
and when the so-called experts have
claimed that the sphinx is
most likely around 4 200 years old
and by the way they say that without any
real proof
nowhere in egypt will you find any
depictions or any type of documents
of the sphinx or when or how it was
constructed
nor do we even know for sure who the
person whose face was recarved into it
there are theories but nothing is
certain think about that you see
the science which is something we hear
about all the time nowadays
tells us that the sphinx is
significantly older by many thousands of
years
the water erosion is there geologists
have extensively studied it and
concluded that the erosion is so
significant
they would have had to have taken many
thousands of years to reach this point
and again
this is despite the fact that the sphinx
was buried in sand for the last
couple thousand years already this
becomes even more interesting when you
consider
all of the recent scientific studies
that have come out explaining how the
sahara desert went from being tropical
green
to a desert in barely a century and as
recently as 4
500 years ago the same general time
frame of the dates that they ascribed to
the great pyramid and the sphinx
for being constructed guys this is
exciting when we were literally living
on the precipice
of learning that the earth changes
naturally and dramatically in far
shorter periods of time
than what most anyone thought was
possible and i think that's exactly what
happened to egypt and why there's
the true history of it is surrounded by
so much mystery and unanswered questions
i really don't think that they chose to
build these incredible structures in the
middle of a barren
deserts although the nile river is there
but it seems to me
especially when we look at the dating
that it's far more likely that they've
started constructing ancient egypt
at the same time that the sahara was
green and by the way
egypt is in the sahara desert and when
you consider the 4 500 year old dates
for the sahara turning from green to
desert and the alleged construction of
the pyramids
which honestly is not surrounded by much
evidence at all
i think this is the missing link here on
explanation why we have no idea
who did it and when but the point is
ultimately this that
the true history of the ancient
egyptians is many thousands of years
older than what we were taught
and it's not until you look at all the
little nuanced details that you can
start to understand this and i believe
that within our lifetimes
we are going to learn many many amazing
things about our true history of
humanity
probably the most incredible discoveries
are a lifetime aside from aliens because
they're apparently already here
now i have a lot more to say and i
couldn't be more excited about my next
video which is going to talk about the
origins of the egyptians and it's going
to tie into many other things
but that video will come after i get
back from peru which i'm heading out on
in just a few days that's right i'm
going to peru for the very first time
ever
in fact my first trip ever to south the
southern hemisphere
and i'm going with brian forester and
ben of uncharted x and it is going to be
amazing we're going to all the notable
sites
and it's going to be incredible i'll be
taking tens of thousands of photos again
and videos that will be used in many
future videos to come which i'm already
sitting on
so many uh images that'll be used in
videos from my trip to egypt
and like i said i'm going to egypt this
october again anyways so i'll be able to
have
all kinds of great videos to come um but
let me see
here follow me on instagram because
that's where i'll be uploading photos
and videos and vlogs
daily so it's bright insight instagram
you'll find a link in the description
and the pinned comment but
with all that said i'm going to wrap
this up i got to go pack my bags for
peru
but my name's jimmy my channel is called
bright insight hit the like button and
subscribe and leave a comment
sharing your thoughts on these relics on
the seven thousand year old ostrich egg
which
with pyramids on them i mean if you
think they're mountains explain leave a
smart comment
and explain away because it just seems i
mean i think their pyramids just look at
them but
let's also talk and leave a comment
about the wood being found in the
pyramid being
hundreds of years older than the age of
the pyramids itself and what's the
explanation for that
as well as leave a comment discussing
the sphinx water erosion that's
something
people like i said it's undeniable but
people still debate it but
it's kind of hard to understand because
it's like the water erosion's there so
when are they
suggesting it happened and how i mean it
was buried for last few thousand years i
already said this
i'll wrap this up anyways again i'm
jimmy with channels called bright
insight
take care everybody